[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
let me kick things off by saying that
i'm using a new mic
so if you guys have any feedback about
how my voice sounds compared to
how it normally sounds then let me know
down below
in today's brief video we're going to be
discussing one
glaringly obvious error made in the film
adaptation of the goblet of fire
the scene in question takes place in the
little hangleton graveyard
shortly after harry cedric are
transported there
via portkey from the maze in the
triwizard tournament
now let me just start off by saying that
this isn't exactly
a plot destroyer but it is a pretty big
mistake
and the filmmakers were forced to fix it
later on
when harry arrives at the graveyard
voldemort is there waiting for him
you see in order for voldemort to return
to his former glory
and achieve once again a proper
corporeal form
he would need to utilize a regeneration
potion
regeneration potions are forms of old
dark magic
that require three things in order to
work
bone of father flesh of servant and
blood
of foe to create this potion wormtail
and
barty crouch junior helped voldemort
source these ingredients
they utilized wormtail's flesh which was
handy
harry's blood hence why they baited him
there and finally
voldemort's father's bone so why were
they in little hangleton
do you ask well that's why voldemort's
father was buried
and it was where the riddle family
hailed from
this brings us to the gravestone of
voldemort's father
who shared a name with voldemort tom
riddle
before the film was released a screen
cap of harry standing in front of tom
riddle's grave
was released however people were quick
to point out
that the grave had a grave error it
showed the name
tom marvolo riddle not tom riddle
this is a big mistake because though
voldemort shared a name with his father
they didn't share middle name he wasn't
a marvolo
essentially what happened was this the
filmmakers believed that the tom riddle
whose name appears on the grave marker
was voldemort not his father the result
was a grave marker mistakenly inscribed
with tom marvolo riddle the dates of
birth and death for tom and his parents
were also incorrectly inscribed the
birth date for tom
was listed as 1915 as opposed to 1905
and the date of death for thomas and
mary riddle
was listed as 1913 two years before
their son is listed
to have been born fall 13 years before
the birth
of their grandson and killer fortunately
before the film was released fans came
to the rescue and alerted the filmmakers
of their mistake
this allowed warner brothers to
digitally correct the grave in
post-production
however the original prop with the wrong
dates
still exists to this day at the warner
brothers studio tour
did you guys know about this did you
ever notice screen caps
floating around that should a grave with
tom marvolo riddle
i think that this is just another
example of how strong and dedicated
the harry potter fandom is sometimes
even proving
the filmmakers wrong if you enjoy the
content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time your wizard harry
you